you might go but my channel is for
everybody that's a losing statement your
Channel's not for everybody it shouldn't
be there's no way with 2.6 billion
monthly active users on YouTube if you
try and reach everybody you end up
reaching nobody narrow down your channel
focus and therefore break through to
views growth subscribers while there's a
lot of generic information out there or
generically positioned content there's
not as much specific content that's
specifically positioned
so how do you stand out on YouTube this
year with Rising competition it feels
like there's massive saturation on
YouTube so is it still possible to get
notice is it still possible to start
from scratch and grow well in this video
I'm going to be talking about 13
different ways to stand out and this is
information that a lot of people won't
tell you and a lot of people don't know
the problem is 99 of creators are
actually approaching YouTube wrong and
by the end of this think media podcast
I'm convinced you're going to have lots
of insights and unlocks about how you
could narrow down your channel focus and
therefore break through to views growth
subscribers and all of the goals that
you ultimately have when it comes to
YouTube and today's episode is brought
to you by
findyourtopic.com we actually have a
brand new free class that is all about
helping you go from confusion to Clarity
with your YouTube channel topic and you
can always check that out in the show
notes and I'll tell you a little bit
more about that later but let's dive
into these 13 different ways to stand
out now this is all about essentially
niching down but it's not what you think
because maybe you've heard Niche down
before and I think that people have
misdefined what that even means now if
you haven't heard the word Niche before
Niche is probably how you're supposed to
say it in America people say Niche
there's the phrase the riches are in the
niches when it comes to building an
online business or a YouTube channel but
this is almost like 13 different ways to
to Niche down Niche down which is
essentially Focus your channel topic and
here's number one you can Niche down by
problem this is a way to get more narrow
on your channel and so we always ask on
think media podcast what problem does
your YouTube channel solve so maybe you
share social media and video marketing
tips that's helping people solve a
problem to learn that maybe you're
getting people the news in under 10
minutes per day and you do it five days
a week their problem is they want
information they want the news but they
want it in a short time maybe you're
helping people become a pro Esports
gamer or how do you lose weight or how
do you get someone to say yes to a date
okay there's a problem but problems not
enough and it honestly even though video
marketing tips is specific it's really
not that specific so what else could we
do well number two you can Niche down by
industry you could Niche down by my
channel is about real estate and imagine
if you combine one and two imagine if
you did social media and video marketing
tips for real estate agents all of a
sudden we're only too deep and we are
getting Fierce Clarity on how you could
stand out be different and find your
unique voice on YouTube and a massive
opportunity Sean how do I compete with
think media sharing video marketing tips
you Niche down by problem and by
industry
so video marketing tips for real estate
agents now of course lots of real estate
agents watch think media media and
listen to our podcast but because of the
positioning we have on YouTube
ultimately you would be much more of a
meaningful specific if you devoted your
channel to just real estate agents their
pain points understanding their problems
and helping them with video marketing to
get leads and customers Etc now you may
already be wondering is it possible to
Niche down too far I think it is it also
if you end up having too small of a
market or too small of an audience then
then you want a second guess but I just
want you to have these 13 different ways
of thinking because they can help you
figure out maybe the next evolution of
your channel and here's another level
there's not just what industry can you
Niche down in but what is the industry
within the industry there's an event in
Las Vegas every year called the Consumer
Electronics Show at its peak I think
over 200 000 people physically fly into
Las Vegas to go to the Las Vegas
Convention Center across multiple
massive Halls Hall a hall B Hall D to
look at TVs smart cars to look at 3D
printers cameras gaming smartphones
smartphone cases speakers it's crazy
when you think about how big consumer
electronics Electronics Tech is it's
absolutely massive so then when you
start thinking about like oh you know I
wanna what industry are you starting
your YouTube channel about oh it's all
about tech well here's the challenge
there's like probably 18 layers deep you
could go into tech for example one of
the things that I think has been helpful
for think media being what it is today
is that the vision of our main Channel
think media is bringing you the best
tips and tools for building your
influence with online video and really
it's the big Focus has been the tools
piece what tools it's kind of a funny
word because you know you might think of
hammers and screwdrivers but we talk
about tools as in cameras microphones
lighting software what are the tools for
specifically creating content so that's
like a niche within a niche within a
niche that is the industry within the
industry and if you go to CES the
Consumer Electronics Show there's
there's aspects of the show makes me
think of one hour video record Academy
students technodad he has a home theater
and home audio channel so he's a tech
YouTuber I'm a tech YouTuber but we're
entirely different why because we're
teaching and doing product reviews
that's the problem in different
Industries or rather Industries within a
bigger end industry technology but he's
doing home audio subwoofers speakers TVs
headphones and there's other channels
that like just do audiophile equipment
he doesn't even really take it that far
except that I've been getting into
lately like amps Dax who ultimately
cares the punch line is what is the
industry number two or what's the
industry within the industry can you be
more of a meaningful specific instead of
a Wandering generality by niching down a
little bit and then one of the questions
I ask myself is is tools for creators
still a large enough market to have a
substantial impact according to the
vision that I have for our company and
for our family and also for just putting
the pieces together this might sound
like this was all just one big strategy
which I think developing the skill of
strategic thinking is one of the most
important things how can you outwork the
competition out strategize the
competition Outlast the competition out
strategize is a big key but it's also
you know I just started volunteering in
my church and the youth Pastor handed me
a video camera and I started doing video
so I leaned into the intersection of my
passion but also I'm thoughtful about
okay what's the market size and also how
can we stand out on this and be more
specific so those are some of the
thinking that you want to have when you
layer these on number three experience
level beginners
middle
or Advanced beginners intermediate
Advanced if you're wanting to stand out
and it feels like there's too much
competition another level would be this
YouTube channel is for beginners another
level would be this is for more advanced
content creators you know we had Alex
hermosi speak at our event and we had
Layla hermosi on the podcast a while
back now Layla hermosi is the I think
they're co-ceos but she really operates
as like a operator of acquisition.com
and she has expressed that like her
passion is Advanced business operations
one of the cool things about her Channel
that I love is it's like really not for
everybody it is actually it's for you
when you've reached a certain level of
pain a certain level of a problem of
like man how do I grow from 10 employees
to 20 employees how do I break through
the 5 million dollar a year barrier or
whatever it's a very specific problem
and so I would argue the experience
science level that she is helping with
is maybe intermediate to even Advanced
compared to 99 of the information that's
on YouTube I would also argue that while
I do believe her channel will grow large
it probably won't grow as large as
beginner advice or people that just want
to start that self-awareness is a
superpower it's also just about doing
what she truly loves best knows best and
has unique skill set to do like her and
Alex can help people I think
acquisition.com helps people
that are five mil plus a year trying to
break through 10 go to like 20 30 40 a
year it's actually a group that's bigger
than you think but it's also radically
smaller than people trying to build six
figure online businesses punchline is
experience level so this advice and
these 13 ways to stand out is also
incredibly invaluable for just starting
a business in general if you are
actually thinking bigger than just a
YouTube channel and thinking I want to
start a business I want to eventually
maybe create a product or do a service
is your product for beginners or is it
for people intermediate or is it for
advanced is your book for is your course
for is your Agency for people at a
particular level it's another layer of
Distinction is it is your stuff just for
first timers entry level positions even
again is it for intermediates is it you
know lately I've been buying books
because I'm a small town kid College
Dropout what the heck do I know about
being a CEO of a company so I've been
buying books on being a CEO I bet those
books don't sell as much much as The
Alchemist by Paula aqualo not only
because that's a classic book but also
because it's not for the masses it's for
a particular skill set so CEO Secrets
video podcast it's a cool name if anyone
wants to design that it doesn't exist is
like a very meaningful specific and you
start saying oh it's too saturated on
YouTube is it or have you just not
really thought through your strategy at
a deep enough level and perhaps
positioned yourself to really narrow
your problem Define the industry figure
out the experience level and number four
is your content for B2B or B to C so
your content could be for business to
business your contact could be to b2c
and and again you might say Sean like
some of this doesn't apply to me because
I'm an entertainment Channel or
something else I want to encourage you
listen to the entire episode because
this will expand your thinking and you
might not be even as business-minded I
know most of our community is but
nevertheless you don't have to even use
all 13 of these you could just pick
three or four and we're going to get
into ones that for sure apply to
everybody these are just different
lenses and Vantage points that you can
use to really Define clarity when it
comes to your channel so B2B business to
business you're helping other businesses
you know we're kind of B2B I think media
especially as we Define we help service
we help Founders and entrepreneurs small
business owners learn video marketing
well you could argue consumers start
businesses because you may just be how
do I start a YouTube business and so we
also recommend business SAS products or
whatever so understanding where you fit
in the market consumer might be again
that end consumer on an entertainment
Channel That's b2c you're you're like
consumers they want to watch Comedy or
it could be b2c in the sense that they
don't want to actually start a business
but they are still interested in
products of some kind or learning about
something here's a couple different
interesting things let's just use real
estate for example real estate buyers
are massive different than Real Estate
Investors which are also different than
agents I would argue that that's maybe
three different YouTube channels one of
the questions I'll get a lot and
sometimes like our video ranking Academy
group was somebody will say like okay I
do have advice for real estate agents
but I'm also an active agent and I'm
helping buyers do I just put it all on
the same channel and put it in a
different playlist and my answer is no
absolutely not like B to B and b2c is
radically different so people that are
looking for a house like I think about
Levi Lasik from living in Dallas he has
multiple channels why because as living
in Dallas channel is for people moving
to Dallas or wanting to sell their house
or buy their house or figure out what
neighborhood so their consumers wanting
to purchase a home or sell a home and
that's one side of things agents want to
learn how to be an agent and investors
want a whole nother set of skills they
probably follow my friend Ryan ponita
and they're trying to figure out how to
flip or how to wholesale and there's 12
13 14 15 different niches within real
estate wholesaling flipping the other
ones you know multi-family uh and so a
single family mobile homes like there's
all these niches within the niches so
are you B to b or B to C and is your
YouTube channel positioned to help
agents or investors or buyers and how
could that apply to you number five
gender is your channel for a particular
gender what's interesting right is the
famous YouTube quote now which is
important to say would be if you try and
reach everybody you end up reaching
nobody you might go well my channel is
for everybody that's a losing statement
your channel is not for everybody it
shouldn't be there's no way with 2.6
billion monthly active users on YouTube
not even Mr Beast not even PewDiePie not
even Coco melon not even T-Series is
even close to reaching
all of YouTube with 2.6 billion monthly
active users and the largest channel
being right around 200 million which I
think is a kids channel or it might be
T-Series or coco melon or whatever like
we're not even close so so nobody's
gonna reach everybody on YouTube
and the reason gender can be so powerful
is you might think about well mainly I
serve women like my content is mainly
now what ends up happening in this are
some of the fears people have it's like
oh man if I go this narrow it's going to
hurt me it's actually a myth it's
probably going to help you if I go this
narrow because technically men would
benefit from my content but like my
content's mainly for women I don't know
if I want to narrow it too much I don't
know you still might get you not only
still might you probably will get
viewers outside of your core Focus but
the key is that you've taken the time to
clarify to Niche down your channel
because that's where the Breakthrough
happens and that's why YouTube is not
saturated because while there's a lot of
generic information out there or
generically positioned content
there's not as much specific content
that's specifically positioned and
powerfully positioned and clearly
positioned on YouTube so then number six
you can do age and generation so imagine
if your YouTube channel and your vision
of your YouTube business was iHelp
Millennial single moms earn extra income
through freelancing
um
so now you're like we've hit gender
women
um season of Life moms Millennial age
problem solved earn extra income
industry of how to earn extra income
would be freelancing and you just
layered all those things together I help
baby boomers learn social media solve a
problem how do you do social media oh
there's too many social media teachers
out there is there is there how many
people are really specifically helping
Baby Boomers with empathy for their
learning style the style of content how
it's presented hmm wow now there's a
whole other opportunity now it might not
be your skill set because you're like I
don't know if I could teach Baby Boomers
I don't know if I understand and so you
again have to put this through the
framework of your experience your
background your vision but number seven
is geography and we're just we're only
halfway through like we've got more
layers and already if you even did a
couple of these you're going to give
yourself an advantage and an edge over
the comp petition but there's more
layers and this again is a huge key
between why some small businesses fail
and some succeed
because if you try to go International
from the start that might be too broad
even National so what if you focus on a
specific area so I mentioned Levi Lasik
from living in Dallas he's crushing his
by the way crushing his channel is not
even close to 100 000 subscribers
so this also dispels the myth that you
need a million subscribers and a gold
play button and 10 million views but
what's fascinating is Levi and we're
going to have him on the podcast he did
I think there is a live stream on the
think media podcast channel that we did
with him but we're going to have him on
the proper podcast one of these days
after six months of doing YouTube
organically only no paid ads and no
other form of advertising he generated
zero real estate transactions but over
the next 12 months him and his partner
Travis which they just co-built this
YouTube channel they did almost 90
million dollars in real estate
transactions which with a three percent
Real Estate Commission with the actual
numbers was around like 2.7 or 2.8
million dollars collected in real estate
Commissions in a 12-month period to be
clear it was 18 months total so of of
investing in YouTube and I want to say
they were under 5 000 subscribers when
they hit that I think they're under 20
000 subscribers right now here's the
point the business vehicle the
methodology of making money the style of
content and the specificity of geography
there's so many there's so many people
in the crater economy who won't make
2.8 million dollars probably in their
career and not because it's not possible
for them it's because they're ignoring
episodes like this it's not because it's
not within their ability or in their
even skill set potentially but it is
because there's a Bible verse that says
my people perish for a lack of knowledge
it is a lack of knowledge and a lack of
discipline for not niching down figuring
out the business model and then
ultimately positioning yourself
potentially related to geography no your
objection might be well Sean I mean
YouTube it isn't though really a
geography based platform people can
watch not just Nationwide but globally
and I agree for most of us we're not
going to Niche down by geography however
in a crowded YouTube World it could be
one of the super keys this video was
brought to you by stream yard stream
yard is our go-to platform for streaming
to YouTube and Facebook with an
incredibly easy to use interface for
built-in branding transition text lower
thirds and seamlessly bringing on guests
it really is one of the best options
when it comes to live streaming and
what's so cool is they've implemented a
brand new feature called local recording
take control of your audio and video
with local recordings by separating out
your audio and video from your guests
this feature gives you the control over
your content for later use making it
perfect for podcasts and video creators
just go to streamwoodthink.com to get
started now because this actually is a
part if you're not subscribed subscribe
to the think media podcast we're going
to be doing like a strategy series these
strategy conversations like what you do
when it feels like there's Goliath all
around and you're wondering how to be
David and kill Goliath geography could
be one of the keys how about some
summers in Alaska it's a vlog Channel
243 000 subscribers a million views per
month interesting because it's not just
vlogging but Alaska is a fascinating
place
and Alaska is part of the positioning of
their channel the niche of their
channels interesting because it's not
just a same old Vlog there's something
unique about it you ever heard of humans
in New York I don't know if they're
really significant on YouTube but I'm
just using them as a geography example
so obviously New York is interesting
there's a lot of reasons why Casey
neistat has been successful but one of
the things I don't think people realize
is yes the storytelling yes the editing
but his geography itself is super
fascinating he's he's he's uh boosted
boarding you know through the streets of
New York flying drones there probably
illegally of course the edits of course
he's super interesting but like crazy
office his office is creative like the
the actual geography of his office like
how interesting his offices like the
location is a distinction the office is
a character New York is a kid like it is
part of the brand and part of the story
you gotta play the hand you're dealt
because you might be sitting here and be
like but I live in a small town and it
sucks and it's not as cool as New York
yeah like welcome that's that's where I
grew up too you know so I so don't try
to be Casey neistat try to be you try to
be you times two try to be me times
three just kidding stupid
um so you know humans in New York the
latest stories uh featuring interviews
with thousands of people in New York
City and it was a photography project
that's a geography branding a lot of
photographers want to get noticed a lot
of Instagram accounts wanted to blow up
humans in New York brought storytelling
to a particular geography so remember
our getting news under 10 minutes
problem so what's the problem I need my
news in under 10 minutes hmm Global it's
a little too broad so what if it was
local so what if it was getting the
Daily News another 10 minutes for
Australia not bad but what if it was
Sydney Australia all right probably
better and is that a big enough market
well I think around 5 million people or
more live in Sydney last time I checked
so pretty good and all of a sudden
you're like all right great I do a news
channel helpful edits consolidate like
the real that one of the biggest content
creation opportunities for the future
future is being a consolidator being a
DJ being somebody that takes just the
overwhelming amount of content that's
coming out the overwhelming amount of
news stories and contextualizing and
synthesizing
synthesizers own the future those who
know how to synthesize a lot of
information and make it easy and
digestible for others it's one of the
most powerful skill sets so all that to
say is I'm sure there's probably already
some competition in that space But if
you're like that's it I love the news I
live in Sydney I would love to do a news
channel there's three different channels
I want to start but like that sounds rad
and probably better than all of
Australia I'm gonna do like Sydney news
in under 10 minutes and it's and you've
now really found a big opportunity so
before we get into number eight you know
a couple ways you could stack these is
like problem plus demographic which is
some of the things we've been talking
about Age season of Life geography
so let's say the problem you solve was
how to make money and how to make money
is even different than how to make money
online because if we started talking
about money you could do Lyft you could
do Postmates you could do like you do a
lot of things but let's say how to make
money online
for single moms
for college students four 30 year old
men
age plus gender right four recently
retired women do you feel
Fierce Clarity rising in your spirit as
you think about this because you're like
my gosh like that just hits and the big
key about this is this is also such a
key to success because it's not even
just about like you standing out and
finding something different it's about
you resonating powerfully with the
person that you're targeting because
someone when when you articulate like
hey welcome this YouTube channel where
we share the best tips of how to make
money online for
recently retired women and you're like
that's me and so like this is my YouTube
channel because the messaging is
matching in a powerful way how to make
money online for Rural High high school
students how to make extra money for
middle-aged fathers with two kids for
recently immigrated 20-somethings see
how powerful this could be but it takes
a lot of work to narrow your focus
number eight size this is another
distinction like if everybody sells big
you can sell small think about this from
the perspective of a business owner
everyone's getting bigger houses what's
a big Trend right now tiny homes
everybody is saying more more more and
consumerism has been rising over decades
and what is the opposite or what is an
answer to that minimalism
so while you would think like is there
different sizes you could you could do
another way to think about this would be
I have a channel just for small
smartphone creators I have a channel
just for helping filmmakers and people
that specifically want to do filmmaking
and cinematic stuff Nolan molt on think
media wants to talk about that more but
I would argue that's not who we're for
defining who you're for and who you're
not for is a big deal because we're for
the average everyday person business
owner content creator that yes wants to
make great crispy videos but isn't
necessarily trying to think about how do
I make films and why we may touch on
that it's a little bit widered out on
our Bullseye it would be because we help
people with video that some of those
videos make sense but where's the
opportunity to go deep in one of those
verticals yes we do smartphone stuff but
what if it was all smartphone just
talking about the think media lens
smartphone creators filmmakers we would
be more YouTubers like you just want you
want to make YouTube videos and we have
different by the way some of this is
channel wide vision but some of this is
specific video opportunities just making
a video for a particular demographic
making a video for recently required
retired women that want to start a
YouTube channel like I I might upload
that video like I don't know like maybe
like uh YouTube tips for college
students like that some of these might
be videos that fit on your channel a
huge key is if you look at what
everybody else is doing what if you do
the opposite size when everybody was
going big trucks and big cars Volkswagen
came out with the Volkswagen Beetle and
it was weird and it was different but it
really resonated by doing the opposite
of what everybody else was doing how
could you apply that to YouTube
obviously you could do an auto Channel
but there's even many in our community
that have dedicated Auto channels some
have dedicated motorcycle channels what
if it was also I don't know the official
term but like other vehicles quads ATVs
you know and motorcycles maybe fits
inside of that I do know people that
have gone they they're going deep in all
these different ways of traveling the
whole boosted board era and the
hoverboards whatever so just size right
another one number nine low price what
if you're the budget and cheap options
do it on a dime cool YouTube channel so
do it on a dime she's gonna also violate
her Niche and violate her brand if she
starts recommending things that aren't
super cheap or DIY but that's the power
is you're narrowing your focus
so you're saying this channel is for
those that are couponing or living on a
budget and so now you're like
you know recently retired tips for
recently retired women for living an
awesome life on a budget you're starting
to get clear but you're you're in you're
including the price side of things
budget or cheap number 10 high price
luxury or expensive options
there's an audience for everything and
see you're also not going to attract
on a fluid audience with the channel
targeted with the budget and cheap body
options and whenever you talk about
money all kinds of money mindsets and
emotions come up relax like this is a
it's important to develop the skill of
strategy to think about this is what
marketing would be this is what
positioning would be and you just being
thoughtful about by the ways there's two
ways to compete in business you go the
Walmart way race to the bottom in price
or you go the Neiman Marcus Nordstrom
way and you go higher priced or even
higher you go the
Toyota way or the Hyundai you know
strategy or you go the Tesla rivian or
Mercedes or Bentley and
you think about there's high price
there's low price so is there
opportunities you could you could apply
all this stuff to faceless channels
that's a whole conversation for another
time but you obviously can make a lot of
videos including scripts and voice over
and b-roll about products and about
things that exist in a channel some
channels are just about like cool
gadgets on Amazon but what an
interesting channel to do a Channel all
about luxury and expensive and these
channels do exist you know like the most
expensive places to travel in 10 10 most
expensive cars and 10 craziest watches
and different things so low price or
high price 11 subcultures is a big one
and it's a big branding opportunity so
we stopped it was tap into subcultures
in fact this is an essential one for
you're listening to this right now this
is time to pay attention because
subcultures is what you layer on top of
all of this which makes things super
interesting so what are some subcultures
there's hip hop as a whole culture
grunge is a culture Punk cosplay geek
straight edge world world of warcrafters
as a culture larpers there's culture
Settlers of Catan Believers are a
culture swifties are a culture uh if the
brand is big enough the individual is
big enough there's dedicated Justin
Bieber Channel channels there's
dedicated Taylor Swift news channels
what's the longevity of that I don't
know but what's the practicality of that
pretty high and if you would be like I
am literally the biggest Swifty like I
could listen talk about study and
research Taylor all day every day well
that is an interesting YouTube channel
because lately as she's been breaking
every record and selling out shows
Reinventing herself over a couple
decades it would it's definitely
something that there's some serious
audience behind it's a subculture
opportunity of positioning it also on a
much more subtle level or rather maybe
not it's not your whole channel is
dedicated to Taylor Swift fans if you
introduce yourself and you're connected
remember we follow people We Vibe with
we connect with the different aspects of
them so we want to learn from someone or
follow someone or connect with someone
with these aspects of subculture
peppered into the content so maybe when
someone discovers that you're like yeah
so I'm a mom of three who
has figured out how to work from home
and make extra money online and I'm
really into raising chickens Taylor
Swift and then people like oh my gosh
that's me too like I love chickens I
love Taylor Swift I'm a mom also and
then you start building these
connections so there's also the
opportunity of weaving the stuff into
your content but these subcultures
paleos vegans carb loaders
carnivore diet people Mets fans Yankee
fans Bears fans you know a book
recommended in thinking about this is a
good book by Seth goding called we are
all weird the rise of tribes in the end
of normal and one of the questions he
asks is why are companies still trying
to build products for the masses let's
flip that why are you trying to build a
YouTube channel for the masses
why are we acting like the masses even
exist the riches are in the niches
the opportunity is to Niche down and to
think about what are like the
subcultures that maybe my whole channel
is about that maybe is tied into my
channel you know there's different
people when I think about sometimes
certain spaces can look all the same if
all the YouTube experts which is maybe a
category I fall into or whatever they
like we look the same which is not true
but just you know roll with me everybody
teaching personal finance like looks the
same sometimes the opportunity is to
just bring a unique Flair to it like so
you bring a punk rock Flair to it your
hair is pink Tattoos Piercings that's
just you you grew up listening to Rancid
or operation IV or forgive me if I'm not
cool enough understanding the niches
punk bands but like you grew up and
that's you and you bring that to a space
that you'd be shocked about how that is
the key that helps you blow up because
and and blow up in context viral for me
viral for you like it blow up because
people are like oh man I resonate with
you because of your your roots your
upbringing your style your dress your
this is why this is a branding
opportunity these distinctions can help
you strengthen your brand and bring your
unique voice to a niche that feels
crowded the reason you start to stand
out is like people like oh I love the
flavor the style of the way you're doing
the problem you solve
of the way that you're doing the
industry that you serve you're layering
in these sub culture distinctions number
12 values belief in ideas you've
probably seen and are very aware that
political party
it's maybe more obvious when we talked
about the news show so the 10 minute
news show if it's conservative leaning
that's going to resonate with some
people if it's liberal leading that's
going to resonate with some people if
you're also trying to be neutral that
may or may not work you know you may
just make everybody mad or like it works
pretty well because you're just trying
to people hate the polarization and
biases that show up on both sides so you
you've figured out and crafted your
voice to resonate in a particular way
but there's also in some cases people
are teaching business and
entrepreneurship and it's obvious that
they lean very conservative or they're
overtly weaving some of those things
into their messaging and remember people
follow people with similar beliefs
people follow people with shared values
so this layer of niching down of course
if you had a family Vlog Channel and you
were like we are a Christian family
trying to raise our children
with Christian ideal ideals and values
in Los Angeles that's kind of
interesting California leans left or
always usually votes left and would
would be with lots of conservatives in
the state you have a lot of liberal
ideology and talk about storytelling we
got some tensions being created it was
some interest being created but now
you've got a geography for your Vlog
you've got some values beliefs and
ideals or religion is involved in this
another layer do you have to use all of
these no but are there a lot more
opportunities available for you to
refine your brand your message yes and
can you stand out on YouTube this year
yes but if you're generic and you're
just an echo and you don't actually take
the time to do the Strategic work where
you stand on stand out on YouTube this
year probably not
another one's causes
you know maybe different causes you get
behind different kind of groups and
we're talking about psychographics so
you know a generalization of these tips
is like there's demographics sometimes
age geography income level
psychographics is interests preferences
values and things like that number 13
distribution
so
as we land the plane
distribution let's first Define it in a
business sense there's been disruption
in certain industries when new
distribution channels arose Sean what do
you mean well let's just talk about like
video content obviously there was the
time of Blockbuster offering to buy
Netflix I think or Netflix trying to
sell to Blockbuster they refused then
Blockbuster eventually goes bankrupt
Netflix arises well what was happening
first you had the local
VHS DVD store Blu-ray then it starts
mailing DVDs at first Netflix starts to
mail DVDs that's a new distribution
Channel a new distribution method so
tapping into mail with with the physical
DVDs come into your house and then
streaming and internet speeds catch up
and we could start streaming Netflix now
it seems crazy that we would do anything
butt stream but that's also that's a
different distribution Channel and
remember Redbox maybe you're still all
ready to get down come on one dollar
let's let's smash a red box grab grab a
TV dinner and just call it a night you
know let's party Redbox is another
distribution channel so DTC direct to
Consumer with all the these
opportunities to start e-commerce online
businesses you don't have to go to a
retail store the brand is just online
and ships direct to Consumer that's a
distribution Channel espresso stands
pull up you know I grew up in the
Northwest lots of espresso stands
different than having to park you know
and get your coffee but quick easy
whatever these are distribution okay so
how does this apply to YouTube well a
couple different ways you can think
about this the style of the show you
produce so John Lee Dumas entrepreneur
on fire back as he tells his story
when at that time is a podcast the
industry of teaching Business and
Entrepreneurship has I would argue
always been crowded like I would also
argue everything is crowded everything
is saturated and if you want to complain
Carl just keep complaining but
ultimately there's something about
seeing the opportunity in every
challenge
and seeing the opportunity in every
problem because what John Lee Dumas saw
when he was starting his show was he's
like well I'm commuting to work every
day and my commute is like 25 minutes
and I'm trying to figure out how to
build a side hustle I'm trying to figure
out how to start my own business
or and I'm also just looking for like
stimulating thought-provoking ideas
and ways people are doing things and I
want to listen to something productive
and I don't want to just listen to talk
radio
but no podcast has a Daily Show
it's all they're all weekly so his
distribution was I want to start
entrepreneur on fire
it's going to be a Daily Show it's all
interviews and they're going to be 25
minutes because that's how long not only
his commute was but he's like that's
also actually the average commute Across
America was interviewing business owners
a unique idea not really
was sharing entrepreneurial tips through
interviews was starting a podcast a
unique idea not really was starting a
YouTube channel you unique idea no not
really was having a Daily Show in a
constraint of a particular amount of
time a unique idea yes and by the way
still is because it's a hard thing to
sustain as well so think about the
layers we're narrowing down now you
figure out the problem you solve the
industry it's in you figure out who it's
for and then you figure out okay it's
it's about 25 minutes or less and it's
seven days a week and then you you also
go oh that sounds like work yeah but now
John Lee Dumas is a multi-millionaire
and you reverse engineered a strategy
because of tapping into these layers of
Distinction and distribution being one
of them shorts is a distribution method
it's a it's a Content format and if you
did something that's under if
everybody's going long form do you go
short form
if everyone do you do Deep dive combos
you know I know a lot of people are
doing that but that's also what some
people want they want they want the real
stuff they want the substance though the
whatever of course this also expands
Beyond YouTube right so you could do
YouTube or are you tapping into other
platforms and you know how passionate am
I am about YouTube but the intelligent
entrepreneur content creator strategist
is just taking
a
30 000 foot View
of the landscape of the industry overall
of what is your goals what is your
vision what is your industry what is
your topic what problem do you solve and
considering all the different
opportunities as you know I could make a
case of Why YouTube should be a big
piece of your content strategy
but you also have to do your own
research and think through your own
thing and there could be other
opportunities that you should lean into
and so what is the way you're trying to
reach your target audience
so a lot of creators shy away from this
level of specificity at this and this is
why they stay stuck especially at the
start one of the big Keys too is that
when you're starting and it's so hard to
get views and subscribers this stuff's
even more important because now you go
oh yeah but Casey neistat it's not New
York it's not the Boost it's just
because he has the influence no it's
it's game over like eventually you reach
that level it's game over like you
you've already broken through you've
already built relationships built
connections so you in a way you've
written your ticket where it's probably
wise to stay on brand to a point for
many people like Dave Ramsey helps
people get out of debt he I'm sure
people would go to his marriage
conference they'd probably go to almost
any conference he does but like he's
still in personal finance like that's
still his thing but he can do whatever
he wants he's built insane levels of
influence and credibility and trust and
an audience that because he met them
with something specific now he can talk
about other things but the mistake
people make especially at the start is
they shy away from this level of
specificity when really this big comes
your biggest opportunity and by the way
if you are interested in
nailing your Niche and you want to your
ideas are flowing but now you're like
Sean help me put this all together I
actually have a training
um and I'm so excited that we're doing
this because one of the biggest
questions we get is Sean I still am
lacking Clarity or now I've got a lot of
ideas but I don't know how to narrow
them down and so we have a brand new
training at findyourtopic.com to watch
the class there and this will help you
go from confusion to Clarity with your
YouTube channel topic and it's gonna
specifically and here's the key help you
find the shortest path to revenue for
you personally because picking the best
money path picking the best business
model it's really bigger than YouTube
It's of course thinking about what's the
bigger business or the bigger bigger
target audience what is the bigger
picture that I'm trying to solve and how
does YouTube support that or weave into
the whole thing so if you just say Sean
I want help Sean I want Clarity I want
to go from confused to Clarity head to
findyourtopic.com and we'll link that up
in the show notes or in the description
my name is Sean Cannell rhymes with you
YouTube channel this is the think media
podcast and I look forward to connecting
with you in a future episode